et on discute de ce sujet avec kerra
bouziane pour le ps alain rémond pour le
pc jean-paul lebarbé pour le medef et
venant un vélo pour la cgpme j'aimerais
qu'on parle du conte pénibilité parce
que c'est aussi de vos revendications
vous souhaitez il soit suspendue voire
arrêter alors avoir un petit peu de mal
à comprendre parce que finalement ce
qu'on pénibilité il est né d'un accord
entre les partenaires sociaux donc
pourquoi maintenant demander son
abrogation
d'avant ce gouvernement de toute manière
si vous voulez c'est après les 35 heures
c'est un conte de pénibilité que de
toute manière est ingérable pour
l'ensemble des entreprises pourquoi on
pourquoi cochez paraît-il sur les
grilles une entreprise une entreprise
elle produit et elle passe plus son
temps aujourd'hui à faire de
l'administratif c'est tellement
compliqué je ne voudrais pas trop
enfoncer des politiques mais au
gouvernement nous prépare des textes qui
sont pratiquement sur le terrain
ingérable pourquoi aujourd'hui renfoncer
encore le clou et de donner des charges
supplémentaires aux entreprises je pense
que ce conte de pénibilité doit être
revue dans des conditions beaucoup plus
simple à établir
la route sera prêt de effectivement nos
salariés qui vont en bénéficier
on doit complètement l'abroger pour les
petites entreprises c'est inapplicable
inapplicable pour une pme comment allez
vous mesurez le dos courbé à plus de 45
degrés de plus de deux heures par
semaine toute l'année avec une boîte 86
à rentrer en vigueur en 2015 non mais
c'est des mesures il faut à tout
simplement l'abroger comment rajouter de
la complexité dans un dispositif qui est
déjà frileux à l'emploi là aujourd'hui
vous lisez ça vous ne pouvez pas
aujourd'hui avoir envie d'embaucher
c'est pas possible
il ya bien des métiers où il ya de la
pénibilité évidemment il y à bien des
hommes ou des femmes qui avec cette
pénibilité la voix leur âge de mortalité
plus faible que bon nombre d'autres
personnes dans la population donc
vialade donc il ya bien la pénibilité
après effectivement c'est un autre il
faut donc que ces gens là après le
retrait avant parce que toute façon les
rails de très courtes leur retraite
résister à 65 ans comme monsieur
hollande nous la mise donc il faut bien
prendre en compte cette pénibilité là
alors qu'après ce soit ingérable mais si
tu veux des
technocrates ont vu ça de leur fenêtre
j'ai raison j'y entre grise moi je veux
bien on peut revoir tout ça mais j'ai le
sentiment que bien souvent on parle du
problème administratif pour éviter le
vrai problème est enlevé ça donc car
disait administratif je pense que ça
peut se régler car l'objectif est
compliqué parce que marisol touraine
disait que c'était simple comme un
effet ricochet sur une fille jusqu'au
marisol touraine a déjà été dans une
entreprise pour voir déjà le
fonctionnement d'un chsct aujourd'hui
alors j'ai donc elle comprend et et sur
toutes les chaînes aujourd'hui la donne
est réservée à l'abri
des politiques qui connaissent pas
l'entreprise mais ils sont entourés par
des gens qui connaissent l'endroit de ce
jeu je me posais juste un mot concernant
le compte des pénibilités il n'est pas
nouveau il avait été déjà mis en place
par l'ancien de l'ancienne majorité a
étendu cela étant dit moi ce qui me
choque aujourd'hui avec dans les
discussions avec le patronat je n'aime
pas trop ce mot parce qu'il englobe les
entreprises c'est qu'ils ont été
d'accord parce qu'il ya eu une
négociation pour la remise en cause de
l'âge de la retraite sur cette année là
contre sur le fond je suis d'accord sur
le fond sion sur le fond mais dès que
ans comme dès qu'on arrive au moment où
il faut avancer les pions et bien le
patron n'est simplement
c'était le patronat mais ne s'était pas
la cgpme on est ronde et des balles si
vous voulez mais
vous retrouvez pas dans mes paroles 6
annoncions sa confiance est passé d'une
association cela étant dit alors ben oui
mais c'est quand même eux qui prennent
les décisions et nous alors je crois je
suis d'accord avec vous monsieur moi je
suis persuadé que ceux qui négocient
aujourd'hui
pour le pour l'entreprise ne représente
pas toutes les entreprises la cgpme lui
ne fait pas partie des négociations à
ces chaises ok je suis choqué ce que je
sais maintenant je vais vous le dire
pourquoi moi j'ai assisté à des pertes
de pénibilité j'aimerais effectivement
on constate une complexité sur le
terrain il y à des dispositions qui ont
été mises au 1er janvier ça doit
s'appliquer on a retenu quatre critères
faciles à mettre en plein travail de
nuit travail répétitif activité dans
l'île de pemba voilà et il en reste six
il en reste six on a un os pour y
travailler et j'invite les représentants
de ceux qui négocient de ceux qui sont
proches de l'entreprise de faire
remonter de travailler pour que cela se
passe le mieux mais en aucun cas
remettre en cause cet acquis social pour
les gens qui souffrent et d'ailleurs on
voit le fait qu'ils ont des travailleurs
on voit le message de sylviane qui dit
j'ai toujours travaillé à la chaîne en
usine mon patron trouve que c'est normal
ce ce droit aux comptes pénibilité je ne
comprends pas que le medef s'oppose à ça
donc on peut la rassurez-vous n'est pas
complètement opposé au principe des
motifs on n'a jamais dit qu'on était
opposé un conte de pénibilité donc mais
de le faire d'une manière claire facile
pour les entreprises et et pour les
petites entreprises si vous voulez que
ça soit pas une usine à gaz ce soit pas
aussi générateur de conflits entre
salariés et aujourd'hui entreprises
parce que la non application de
administratives et je vous rejoins de ce
conte pénibilité ont évidemment il ya
des métiers pénibles évidemment il faut
mettre les meilleures conditions mais ce
qu'on veut demain que ces métiers
évidemment évidemment on est d'accord
mais est-ce que ça passe de maintenant
une mécanisation la disparation de
l'emploi aussi qui dit faut faire
attention à ça
mais thierry bertoux sang et or ça va
être compliqué mais un métier qui est
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui pénible
il est si on le contraint encore plus il
faut l'améliorer dans ces conditions
mais faut pas que ce soit un frein à
l'embauché que le patron demain par la
non-application possible dans sa boîte
soit contraint b2 de mécaniser par
exemple c'est aussi peut-être un c'est
peut-être un un danger
juste une dernière chose évidemment on
est vous parlez de gouvernement actuel
et gouvernement nous vous savez c'est
pas notre problème c'est pas le sens
bien on fait pas de politique madame
madame la députée ont fait pas de
politique aujourd'hui que ce soit de
droite ou de gauche aujourd'hui on
aurait le même discours parce qu'il ya
urgence et je tiens à souligner les
actions locales de certains de nos
députés avec qui on l'a des relations
très proches laurent grandguillaume par
exemple qui a un député de la majorité
qui travaillent avec nous sur
l'entreprise qui nous aident et qui nous
aident et qui comprend quand on lui
parle des professions réglementées quand
on lui parle de la pénibilité mais si si
si mais c'est pas les vues j'avais 10
ans et j'avais eu ces discussions et
c'est avec laurent grandguillaume
les seuils ses clients il a il a
effectivement si discuter avec nous et
il a proposé à son gouvernement des
aménagements de textes donc évidemment
on a on a besoin de nos élus locaux on a
besoin de nos députés qui remonte
l'information des tpe pme parce qu'elles
sont plus proches du terrain et on
sourit c'est pas partisan ce qu'on fait
absolument pas ses partisans pour les
entreprises et pour les salariés
également parce que encore une fois je
pas qu'on oppose ces deux ces deux
vecteurs de la richesse d'un pays il ya
deux bons nuls il ya de bons patrons
voilà cet échange pierre gattaz sera
mardi à dijon sais pas si vous allez
venir le voir c'est sa première visite
dans la région alors il vient pour
l'opération un million d'emplois et puis
réclament aussi la mise en place d'un
nouveau pacte social dit il alors ça
veut dire quoi ce pacte social parce qu
il a fait des déclarations assez
tonitruante à ces derniers temps pierre
gattaz demandant notamment à la france
de sortir
de la convention 158 de l'oit et je
croix celtique
oblige à justifier d'un licenciement ça
va très mal est-ce que c'est pas de la
provocation alors là encore une fois si
vous voulez le fait de lancer des
opérations médiatiques permettent
effectivement de se réunir au plus
rapidement possible moi le medef il
propose effectivement de se réunir avec
tous les partenaires sociaux avec tous
les politiques tous les élus pour
pouvoir effectivement construire une
années 2020 beaucoup plus puissantes et
et c'est vrai que quelque part il faut
se réunir
autour d'une table pour pouvoir en
disant que c'est ça le nouveau pacte
social
on va pas on va pas le mettre en avant
encore il et il n'est pas négocier il
n'est pas en place il n'est pas discutée
il faut à peine connu il est un fait que
nous parlons des questions les
partenaires sociaux je crois que je les
dis je le redis les entreprises 110
salariés ça n'existe pas donc on est
prêts nos salariés aussi bien que
n'importe qui donc monsieur gattaz vient
le 9 à dijon c'est là sans doute très
bien reçu par monsieur rebsamen à un
moment puisque monsieur rebsamen
avec les propos qu'il a tenus ces
dernières semaines et notamment contre
les demandeurs d'emploi ils sont
choquants à un point incroyable
j'invite mois les salariés de sanofi et
tous les demandeurs d'emploi de dijon a
amené un petit paquet de mouchoirs et c
est ma camarade isabelle de almeida qui
m'a glissé sa fière des mouchoirs au
grand palais c'est quand
un pour les donner à monsieur gattaz qui
pleure pleure pleure et que comme ça ils
pourront dire sur ça rapidement moi je
soutiens françois rebsamen dans les
mesures qu'il a annoncé qu'il n'a pas pu
effectivement
d'autres mesures que françois rebsamen
sur lesquels ils travaillent et qui sur
lesquels on est très favorable oui il
faut vraiment aussi avoir le les seuils
travail sur les seuils avec une
expérience une expérience une expérience
pardon une expérience qu'il avait
proposé sur un an ou deux pour voir le
seuil des 49 50 ce qu'aujourd'hui
certaines entreprises aux salariés sa
coupe à sa 56e chsct cette expérience
qu'il voulait me c'était pour permettre
d'avoir ce freins récurrents
l'embauchent qu'on rencontre chez nos
pme qui prennent pas le 50e ils ne
prennent pas pour pas passer au dessus
du seuil puisque c'est contraignant donc
ça cette expérience là et elle et elle
est à mon avis applicable et ça générera
de l'emploi pas de manière spectaculaire
mais j'en suis sûr deuxième ce soit
spectaculaire
non mais c'est un mais des salariés
soient récemment sur les seuils
effectivement on y est favorable quand
il parle et moi je comprends pas qu on
s'offusque de choses qui sont du bon
sens quand il parlait du contrôle en
l'occurrence des arrêts maladie et ces
choses là mais ceux qui sont 90% de la
population qui se comportent bien ne
doivent pas se fier à cerner ils ne
doivent pas se sentir concerné il ya qu'
il ya que la minorité non silencieuse
parce que les abus à l'arrêt de travail
on en connaît plein pourquoi vous
synthétiquement la sécurité sociale
manque 2 milliards chaque année rappelé
au delà vous n'aidez contre 20 milliards
pourquoi on s'offusque de ce je
m'offusque pas de ça mais parle d'abord
des membres du
ca me dire des génisses concernant les
seuils en vo on nous sort à tout bout de
champ l'exemple
idyllique de l'allemagne les seuils en
allemagne ses cinq salariés l'allemagne
les le dimanche et les jours fériés sont
des jours de repos donc quand on compare
avec certains pays il faut comparer tous
en allemagne quand vous licencier
quelqu'un si ça passe au tribunal et que
vous avez tort vous êtes obligé de le ré
embaucher et je pourrais vous en dira
plein parce que j'ai fait une étude
comparative sur sur les 2 sur les deux
dons viennent y en a bien sûr il
faudrait je viendrai je vienne alors là
c'est la clé alors la grande bretagne
c'est un contre à 0,1 vous savez pas si
vous on va vous appeler ou pas alors
allé chercher un travail allez acheter
un appartement avec un contre à 0,1 et
si c'est ça ce qu'on cherche
entreprise même si la wii mais où en en
allemagne en angleterre et chez nous et
les femmes mûres inclus raison et les
femmes sont plus à la maison parce qu'à
pas de crèches parce qu'à pas notre du
boulonnais américain qui n'a peut-être
pas juste des lieux
merci non plus merci donc à la
merci elle a rédigé on arrive déjà au
terme de cette émission s'est désolé ça
m'a prévenu tôt en tout cas merci à tous
d'avoir accepté cette invitation je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez revoir cette
émission sur notre site internet
bourgogne point france 3 point fr la
semaine prochaine j'en ai dit un mot
tout à l'heure nous parlerons des
professions réglementées de la loi
macron avec notamment la présence de la
députée cécile untermaier qui préside
justement la mission d'information sur
ces professions juridiques réglementées
pour l'heure le doubs stress continu
mercialys